These are all characters with bounties over
1 billion berries in One Piece as of the latest
chapters of the manga, how they got their
respective bounty and whether they actually
deserve it or not.
At the bottom of the list of the most valuable
pirates in One Piece is Jack, the drought,
third commander of the beast pirates.
Jack is a giant fishman that has eaten the
ancient mammoth zoan devil fruit with incredible
physical power and endurance.
He was known for his cruel and brutal methods
like the gas attack and Torture he conducted
on Zou, the island of the minks.
He is fiercely loyal to his captain Kaido
and was willing to die for him during the
raid on onigashima, where he took on the elite
force of the minks in their sulong form.
For both his power and his brutal nature,
Jack earned a bounty of exactly 1 Billion
berries, just making the cut for this exclusive
club of pirates.
Since he got defeated during the battle for
Wano and the beast pirates got captured with
the situation of their captain unknown, Jack's
bounty might actually be reduced.
Nonetheless he has proven to us, why he is
in the 1 billion club.
Just above Jack is Vinsmoke Sanji, the first
of 4 straw hat pirates on this list and the
official cook of the crew.
Sanji has proven his worth and strength as
a member of a new Yonko crew over and over
again.
Sanji has grown incredibly strong as a fighter,
unlocking the abilities of his Vinsmoke DNA
over the course of Wano on top of his fire
abilities.
He can do sky walk and has some of the best
observation haki in the crew.
He managed to take down Queen, Kaido's second
commander and help Luffy reach the status
of 1,032,000,000 berries, putting him in the
top 20 of highest bounties in the story, which
I think is more than justified.
Next is Charlotte Katakuri, first commander
of the Big Mom pirates.
Katakuri has basically been leading the Yonko
crew whenever Big Mom was on one of her hunger
pains.
Like most first commanders, he enjoys incredible
respect throughout the pirate world and has
incredibly advanced observation haki abilities,
so far only shared by the likes of Luffy and
Kaido, that allow him to look slightly into
the future.
He has excellent control over his incredibly
powerful devil fruit and excellent leadership
skills.
His defeat by Luffy was only due to his sense
of honour and his willingness to let Luffy
grow and evolve during their fight.
Despite his defeat, he is a true force to
be reckoned with and the second strongest
fighter among the big mom pirates, earning
him rightfully a 1,057,000,000 berry bounty.
With Katakuri in between, after Sanji, we
have two more Straw hat pirates in a row.
First is Jinbe, former warlord of the sea
and helmsman of the straw hat pirates.
Next to jack he is the only other fishman
on this list.
Not only was Jinbe an equal among the likes
of Mihawk, Doflamingo and Boa Hancock, he
is also the most powerful user of the legendary
art of fishman karate.
He is able to use and manipulate the forces
of the ocean and fight under water like no
one else.
This would be a great feat by itself, but
in a world of powerful devil fruit users,
who are weak against sea water, he is a truly
powerful weapon for his captain.
Put on the deepest level of impel down and
now part of emperor luffy's crew, Jinbe has
more than earned his impressive bounty off
1,100,000,000 berries.
Just a bit ahead of him is another straw hat,
Luffy's second in command and contender for
the title of the strongest swordsman in the
world, Roronoa zoro.
No one doubts that Luffy's right hand man
belongs on this list.
If anything he ranks to low here.
Zoro has been close to luffy's equal in power
throughout the story.
Not only has he been acknowledged and trained
by the strongest swordsman in the world, Dracule
Mihawk, but he also is a yielder of Conquerers
haki.
Zoro has been growing stronger and more terrifying
as a fighter throughout the entire story,
always willing to sacrifice his life for his
honour as a swordsman and the safety of his
crew.
He is fiercely loyal to Luffy and closely
resembles the relationship between Silvers
Rayleigh and Gol D. Roger.
After escaping death, cutting Kaido, the strongest
creature in the world and taking down King,
Zoro has more than earned his 1,111,000,000
bounty.
Making a bit of a jump of over 200 million
berries, we have the 3 remaining yonko commanders
on this list, starting out with Queen the
Plague, second commander of the beast pirates.
Like everyone else in the higher echelons
of the crew, Queen also wields a powerful
ancient zoan devil fruit, that they have modified
with cyborg technology.
Not only are they an incredible powerful fighter,
but they also have incredible technological
and scientific knowledge, on the level of
Sanji's father Judge Vinsmoke or Caesar Clown.
He is known for his love for torture and cruelty.
However he has been portrayed as more of a
comic character throughout the wano Kuni arc.
Maybe his bounty is a bit high, but his 1,320,000,000
berries are still reasonable.
On rank 15 we have one of the coolest characters
in the story with one of the best devil fruits.
Marco the Phoenix, first commander and doctor
of the Whitebeard pirates.
Marco has fought against the most powerful
people in the one piece world and always made
it out alive and with little to no damage.
He fought the admirals at marineford, Blackbeard
and his men during the payback war and of
course Big Mom as well as Kaido's commanders.
And we don't even know who else.
Marco is not only incredibly smart, but has
possibly the most useful Devil fruit in the
story.
His mythical phoenix fruit not only gives
him great attack power and the ability to
fly, but also gives him the properties of
a logia fruit plus strong healing abilities.
Like a Phoenix, Marco seems almost impossible
to kill and is able to heal large groups of
people during battle, as he proved during
the battle on Onigashima.
If anything his 1,374,000,000 berries almost
seem too low.
Especially since one place above him sits
King, who faced off against Marco together
whit queen.
Nonetheless King of course deserves a place
on this list.
He is Kaido's right hand man.
A swordsman who has also eaten a winged ancient
devil fruit.
This is almost a little wasted on King however,
as he has wings of his own.
As possibly the last surviving member of the
Lunarian race, the former gods who lived on
top of the red line, King possesses incredible
powers including the ability to naturally
generate fire.
While he just barely lost to zoro during Wano,
it's not hard to see how this man who stood
side by side with Kaido would have gotten
his 1,390,000,000 berry bounty.
And with this, the remaining characters are
part of one of 3 groups, former warloards,
part of the worst generation or a yonko.
Starting with place 13 and the pirate empress
boa Hancock.
Hancock not only is the leader of the Kuja
pirates, a tribe of legendary female warriors
living on Amazon Lilly, but she also is one
of the few confirmed people who can use conquerers
haki.
On top of that, she wields one of the most
powerful devil fruits in the story, that is
able to turn anyone with strong emotions for
her into stone.
An ability so powerful , that Blackbeard wanted
to get his hands on it no matter what.
Hancock has held herself against a number
of powerful enemies and survived the horrors
of slavery at the hands of the celestial dragons.
With the warlord system abolished her new
1,659,000,000 berry bounty shows how powerful
luffy's self-declared future wife truly is.
Next in line is another former warlord of
the sea that has just made his comeback into
the main story.
Sir Crocodile, founder and commander of the
newly founded cross guild organisation.
Crocodile not only managed to bring an entire
country under his control in Alabasta, but
he also is experienced in leading powerful
organisation, like the Baroque works together
with Nico robin and now an even more powerful
one together with Dracule Mihawk.
Crocodile was not afraid to face Whitbeard
or Akainu during the marineford war and apparently
has grown a lot stronger.
His new bounty of 1,965,000,000 berries seems
quite high, considering that he lost to a
Luffy with no haki abilities yet, but I'm
very excited for him to show us why he deserves
the 12th highest bounty in the story.
Now however, we not only break into the top
10 of the list, but we also make a jump of
over 1 billion berries Into the 3 billions.
Sharing places 9, 10 and 11 are 3 members
of the worst generation, all with exactly
3 billion berries.
Monkey D. Luffy, Trafalgar D Law and Eustass
Captain Kid.
These three were already protrayed as rivals
and roughly equals during the sabaody archipelago
arc.
Now the trio has teamed up to take down two
of the former emperors, Big Mom and Kaido.
Kid has an incredibly powerful magnet devil
fruit ability combined with a crazy blood
lust, a darker version of Luffy, that was
able to stand his ground against the Yonko
with his brute force.
He even tried attacking shanks before, where
he lost an arm and has only been growing stronger.
Law meanwhile has one of the, if not THE most
valuable devil fruit there is, the op op no
mi, that not only has incredibly fighting
abilities, but that also is capable of granting
immortality.
Law is incredibly intelligent and truly shines
as a supporting fighter in combination with
a brawler like Luffy or Kid.
I personally find both their bounties a little
too high.
Yes, they took down big mom and I understand
that Eiichiro Oda wanted to underline the
rivalry between the three captains, but I
think a bounty sightly below Luffy would have
been more reasonable.
After all he fought Kaido alone, while these
two teamed up.
Nonetheless they belong on this list without
any question.
Luffy on the other hand as the captain of
the straw hat pirates and protagonist of the
story has been earning his bounty from day
one.
He has changed the one piece world, like almost
no one else.
He has taken down the most powerful creature
in the world and awakened his legendary Sun
God Devil fruit during the fight.
A fruit feared so much by the world government,
that they tried to erase its true nature and
name from history.
Luffy has some of the most powerful allies
in the story and is no longer considered as
an underdog, but a serious contender for the
pirate king crown by the entire world.
Slightly ahead of luffy is the other new emperor,
The great jester Buggy the clown.
Buggy is a real wildcard in the story.
He has failed his way up so much, you can't
really help but wonder if he's not some secret
genius, that is orchestrating things from
behind the scenes.
However, at least as of right now, buggy is
a nobody, who has lied and tricked his way
into a position he doesn't even want to be
in, at the mercy of crocodile and mihawk as
the official leader of the cross guild organisation.
Buggy's real bounty should probably be either
10 million berries or 10 billion berries.
Only time will tell.
For now at least, Buggy sits at 3,189,000,000
berries.
His commander and strongest member of the
cross guild organisation is only one rank
above him.
The 'marine hunter' and strongest swordsman
in the world, Dracula mihawk.
Mihawk without any doubt is one of the strongest
10 characters in the entire story.
He is able to fight with basically anyone
and might have been able to become a yonko
himself, if buggy didn't steal the spot by
accident.
Mihawk has been able to spar with shanks and
even surpasses him in in his swordsman skills.
He is sure to have extremely powerful haki,
demonstrated by his supreme grade sword yoru,
that he turned into a black blade.
Mihawk is a bit of a wild card in his own
regard too and whoever ends up having him
as an ally will be a force to be reckoned
with.
Rightfully so, his new bounty after the abolishment
of the warlord system is a proud 3,590,000,000
berries.
Barely missing the top 5 and the club of the
4 billion bounties is the third current emperor
of the sea and most likely luffy's biggest
rival for the throne of pirate king: Marshall
d.
Teach aka blackbeard.
Teach has laid low for years, staying under
the radar and carefully planning his now quite
quick rise to power.
He has assembled a crew of the most dangerous
and powerful pirates in the world, has started
hunting devil fruits for his crew and is the
only known person who has successfully eaten
2 devil fruits.
As one of the biggest threats and most dangerous
people on the planet right now, Teach rightfully
has gained a new bounty of 3,996,000,000 berries.
Also here a few characters that might be somewhere
in this list too, but who's bounty we don't
know yet: Silvers Rayleigh, Rocks D. Xebec,
Shanks' admirals, Blackbeard's admirals, Monkey
D. Dragon, and the golden lion Shiki.
Which brings us to the 5 highest known bounties
in one piece and your chance to quickly subscribe
to the channel if you haven't already.
Because you're awesome.
Just as awesome as the number 5 and probably
most legendary character in the series, the
captain of the red hair pirates and last remaining
yonko of the original 4, red hair shanks.
Shanks has been a very big mystery for the
longest time in the story, and to a certain
degree still is.
However, we now know that he isn't an emperor
for nothing.
As a former member of the Roger pirates, that
has grown up on the pirate kings ship, he
has spent his whole life training by the side
of the strongest people in the world.
He has the strongest haki in the series with
next level abilities to cancel out other peoples
haki and a presence that can even stun a marine
admiral.
He is a master swordsman and on top of that
he also has political power and connections
second to no other pirate.
All of that without having eaten a devil fruit
or having even a single devil fruit user in
his crew.
Rightfully so shanks has a bounty of 4,048,900,000,
which is maybe even too low for him.
The next three places are all held by former
Rocks pirates.
A little big above shanks, probably due to
her time as a yonko is Big Mom.
Big mom, is a true force of nature.
Not only is she practically indestructible,
she also wields one of the most terrifying
devil fruits that allows soul manipulation.
She has a crew of powerful children of hers
and is a master in intel gathering and political
manuevering.
Even though she has has now been taken down,
for decades she was the strongest woman in
the entire one piece world with a 4,388,000,000
bounty.
In 3rd place is her former crew mate and later
ally, the strongest creature in the world
Kaido.
Another true force of nature and gigantic
size, seemingly invincible with a mythical
dragon zoan fruit that made his powers even
more ridiculous than they already were.
Kaido was feared and respected by everyone.
His presence along was enough to keep any
other yonko or the government from interfering
in his affairs in wano.
He was convinced he could change the world
and bring about the return of joy boy, which
ultimatley he did, even if he was a terrible
person.
His brutal methods and colossal power put
him above big mom at 4,611,100,000 berries.
Which leaves us with the 2 highest bounties
in the story:
Number 2 is Edward Newgate aka Whitebeard,
the former strongest man in the world with
5,046,000,000 berries.
The only person above him is of course the
first pirate king Gol D. Roger, only because
he found the last island and learned the true
history.
They were at the pinnacle of an entire era.
Two absolute legends.
The strongest and most influential pirates
in the story so far.
Roger with the number one bounty of 5,564,800,000
berries.
So the real question now, is who will surpass
these two.
Two likely candidates are Luffy and Shanks,
and if you want to know why you should really
not miss out on this video right here.